-I have an announcement
to make tonight.
I have --
I wanted to do so--
Jennifer Lopez and I wanted
to do something together.
Always.
-Always.
-Yeah. And I can tell
the audience wants it.
You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And so I said to Jennifer,
I go, "Let's do a song."
And she -- she said, "No."
Immediately.
[ Laughter ]
Just -- not even --
didn't even think about it.
Didn't even think about it.
Politely said no.
So I said, "What about maybe --
how about like a rom-com?
Romantic movie.
You know, we could do --
Didn't even --
She almost hung up the phone.
So, I said, "All right,
let's think of something."
We did want to work together.
Maybe it was more me that
wanted to work with Jennifer.
[ Laughter ]
But I go, let's do something --
I go, "I've written kids books,
you know, children's books."
She goes --
And I know she loves her kids.
They're always here with her
when she's on the show.
I go, "Let's do --" She goes,
"That'd be a great idea."
So, I came up with a great idea.
This is it.
"Con Pollo."
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Con Pollo"!
So, here is the idea.
"Con pollo"
means "with chicken."
When you think of con pollo,
you think of --
-Arroz con pollo.
-No, no, no.
-Oh, eating a chicken.
-No, you're not eating
the chicken in this.
This -- you're friends
with the chicken.
-Your friends eat the chicken.
-No one eats the chicken.
[ Laughter ]
Chicken is your buddy in this.
No one eats the chicken
at all in this.
"Con Pollo,"
it's a this-or-that book.
Okay? And basically, like,
what you do is you --
you learn Spanish as it --
you teach your kids Spanish.
So you go, "Do you want to go
to the beach,
or do you want to go
to la playa con pollo?"
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I dedicate this to my
high school Spanish teachers,
Mrs. Shermer, Mrs. Wasinski,
and Mrs. Houlihan.
[ In Irish accent ]
The best Spanish teachers around
this side --
this side of the rainbow.
Mrs. Houlihan was there
to teach me my Spanish.
[ Normal voice ] But I do want
to give a shout-out to them.
Some are not with us.
But your names will now be in
schools and libraries forever.
So, thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Con Pollo."